all right a couple other little things I
want to check in on and then we'll do
just a brief election update based on
the things that have happened while
we've been filming today our good
friends over at the good liars that's
Jason and davram they spoke to a woman
recently who says that right now Dr
fauci is in jail in Guantanamo Bay and
it's not just Dr fauci it's Obama
and it's also Clinton Obama
I go back to the question we've been
trying to answer for a long time
when
is it a cult member with a cult belief
when is it an ignorant person who simply
misinformed if the and if they're shown
the truth they will revise their views
and when is it mental illness
I don't know the answer let's see if we
can figure it out here what do you think
about Anthony fauci
oh my God I can't even believe he made
it this far
no I just the guy's gone
really who else is in gimmo besides
Anthony fauci you know you got Hollywood
there you've got politicians you've got
Elites the clintons are there the Obamas
are there you know um it goes on and on
I don't want to be the one to sit here
and and misquote somebody or say
something but you don't want to say
anything irresponsible exactly right
like fauci Clinton and Obama are
currently at Guantanamo Bay
what do we do with this what do we do is
this we need better education
is this we need antipsychotic medication
like what is it that needs to be done
the most actionable takeaway at every
election should be she probably voted
yesterday I guess I mean sometimes these
people are super involved in this
superficial way
but then they don't actually vote but
let's let's assume she voted yesterday
we need to be voting to counteract the
vote of someone who thinks Dr fauci is
in prison right someone emailed me and I
don't know whether some of you think
there's something to this
someone wrote to me and said you know
David there's a reason why it's mostly
like baby boomer types who we see
repeating this crazy conspiracy stuff
that they get from Facebook and
elsewhere this is this is the view of
one of our viewers and what they said is
Baby Boomers simply didn't grow up with
the internet and social media people my
age didn't grow up with it but it sort
of cropped up when we were
10 12 14 and then people like my little
sister's age quite literally grew up
with it and what this person said is
a lot of folks just don't understand
how to discern fake news and
conspiracies
and actual
reliable information they don't know how
to discern reliable and unreliable
internet sources a fake News website is
designed just like New York times.com
and they quite literally can't tell the
difference
I don't know like is that is that ageist
is there something to the age thing
I mean my mom's never calling me and
falling for this stuff so I I don't know
that that's really what it's about but
it was an interesting idea
um just so everybody knows Dr fauci's
not at Guantanamo Bay
Barack Obama's also not there and
neither Bill nor Hillary or even Chelsea
Clinton are being held at Guantanamo Bay